You all know I call things as I see them.
And right now, it's time to call the virus
situation as I see it.
Idiots and bad people are destroying our ability
to curb this virus as soon as possible.
Their behavior is putting people at risk and
it will cause people to die unnecessarily.
People who didn't need to die.
Now, I'm.
I'm not just talking about the people in our
government.
I'm also talking about just regular old people.
You might Ruma.
And by old, I just mean regular people, not
elderly.
I did a story back in February of last year,
about 13 months ago, called It's time to admit
that many Americans are stupid.
And clearly, this struck a nerve.
It got more than six hundred thousand views
or very positive reaction.
More than 16000 likes.
But a lot of people didn't like it.
A lot of people felt that it was an attack
on them to some degree or on on people who
just lacked education.
And this is not what we are talking about.
We have never had a clearer case of bad and
dumb people will be the death of us than what
is happening now in the era of Corona virus.
Corona virus has exposed the deficits in our
systems, the deficits in our health care system,
in our economy, in our president's capacity
to deal with a crisis, a total lack of capacity,
that is.
But we're also hurting because of bad and
dumb people.
And I'm going to go through some examples
with you today.
Of course, the context being to stop the spread
of the virus absent functioning antivirals,
a vaccine, antibody treatments, all of which
are under development.
It's gonna be a while.
We need to reduce exposure and transmission,
stop gathering in large groups, work from
home, stay away from other people, all this
stuff.
Many states are realizing it, shutting down
bars and restaurants and gatherings, even
as large as 25 people.
Look at just a sampling of what happened over
the weekend.
This is just a handful of examples.
There are hundreds or thousands of these.
Oklahoma Republican Governor Kevin Stitt posted
a tweet of himself out with his kids in a
very crowded restaurant saying, Eating with
my kids and all my fellow Oklahomans at the
collective OKC.
It's packed tonight.
This is the exact opposite of what medical
experts say we should do.
And of course, we live in a world where one
party has decided.
Medical experts are basically just people
with opinions which we can ignore if we don't
like them, because it's just like saying,
I think low taxes are good.
It's just an opinion.
Our Republican governor here in Massachusetts
is taking this seriously, activating a system
to get nurses from out of state licensed in
state within 24 hours to keep up with demand,
saying closed schools work from home, starting
a restaurant and bar closure other than takeout
and delivery starting tomorrow.
And meanwhile, the Oklahoma governor is bragging
about being at a packed restaurant with his
kids.
Is this weaponised ignorance or is this a
bad person?
You tell me.
Governor eventually deleted the tweet because
of the obvious blowback.
People are hoarding.
People are hoarding food of all kinds.
People are hoarding toilet paper.
This is creating an artificial shortage.
There was no expectation that the supply chain
was actually going to be disrupted for toilet
paper, nor that toilet paper usage would actually
go up.
But people are going crazy and they're doing
it with food as well.
Here is video of people rolling around on
the ground, pushing each other, yelling at
each other and fighting for toilet paper at
some big box store.
I don't even know where this is.
Doesn't matter.
It's happening all over for toilet paper.
One one for one person.
So, again, this is all started by rumor about
a shortage.
People go fight for toilet paper and they
cause a shortage because people are hoarding
it.
If people just kept buying toilet paper at
their normal rate, using it at their normal
rate, there'd be no shortage.
There'd be no scuffles for people pushing
each other in order to get grabbed.
Toilet paper.
Are these stupid people or are they bad people?
I don't know the answer.
More and more in blue states, people are staying
home.
St. Patrick's Day parade here in Boston canceled.
If you're from the area, you know just how
big of a deal that is.
Not everywhere, though.
Here's a girl at some kind of St. Patrick's
Day street party talking about, well, I'm
21, I'm immunocompromised, but I don't care
because I take supplements.
I have a compromised immune system, but I'm
still only 20.
But I'm not even worried because I just take
supplements and like I self-medicate, so it's
fine.
Is this a dumb person or is this a bad person
for lack of a better term?
South Korea has tested large numbers of asymptomatic
20 to 29 year olds and found that a whole
bunch of 20 to 29 year olds who feel fine
have the virus and they are spreading it all
over.
If they do what this girl is doing, it has
to stop.
Here is Republican Congressman Devin Nunes
s going on Trump brownnoser Maria Bartiromo
program on Fox and saying, hey, you know what?
This is a great time to go out to a restaurant.
It's not that busy.
You can get right in and get a table where
there's a lot of concerns with the economy
here because people are scared to go out.
But I will just say, one of the things you
can do if you're healthy, you and your family,
it's a great time to just go out, go to a
local restaurant.
Yeah, likely you can get in, get in easily.
There's you know, let's not hurt the working
people in this country that are relying on
wages and tips to keep their small business
a sympathetic run to the don't run to the
understand.
Just don't run to the grocery store and buy
buy, you know, four thousand dollars of food.
They're going out to your local local pub,
very sympathetic to what's going.
No pushback from Maria Bartiromo.
Should that be criminal?
What Devin Nunez said, I tweeted asking, should
this be criminal?
A whole bunch of my Twitter followers said,
yeah, well, Devin Nunes is doing there should
be criminal.
Now, Devin Nunes isn't wrong to be concerned
about the economy.
The economy is in a freefall.
But the problem is the systemic structural
one.
The solution isn't to now say, well, we have
to just keep going to bars and restaurants.
What we need is a system of paid sick leave.
So he can be less concerned about the restaurant
employees not having disbanded the pandemic
response team, having a functioning health
care system.
These are structural problems.
They don't get solved by saying go at the
individual level and continue to engage in
the behavior that's spreading the disease.
If we're going to have this level of both
stupidity and just straight-up disregard for
others, we are in very, very serious trouble.
And as we see the partisan divide, Republicans
half to a third is likely to be worried about
coronaviruses.
Democrats to be taking action around coronaviruses
Democrats.
We are in a situation that is only going to
get worse.
That's where the data's pointing
right now.